hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled
keynote presentation viromics lessons
from ocean soil and humans this webinar
is part of the 2021 microbiology virtual
week and i'm susie valdez of labyrinth
and i will be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots so let's get
started before we begin i want to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing these presentations just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen
and as a reminder this presentation is
educational and offers free continuing
education credits click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right hand corner of your
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits i now
present today's speaker dr matthew
sullivan a professor of microbiology and
civil environmental and geotic
engineering from the gordon and betty
moore foundation investigator and he's
the co-director of osu infectious
disease institute in microbial
for complete biography of our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen dr sullivan welcome
you may now begin your presentation sir
thank you so much susie it's great to be
here
um my lab studies how ocean viruses
impact marine microbes and we do this to
understand how the oceans work how
they're going to be impacted by climate
change how they may cause climate change
but we also do this because oceans are
complex communities and this means that
by pioneering technologies and
approaches in the ocean ecosystems we
can get a road map for how we can apply
and understand virus studies
in a complex system and we can use that
then as a roadmap to study viruses and
other complex systems these these
approaches are generalizable
so
here's where we're going today first why
do we study viruses and particularly
we're currently focusing on viruses of
microbes in fact double-stranded dna
viruses of microbes
then i'll spend a lot of time focusing
on the oceans
under the themes of patterns processes
and paradigms
and then we're going to talk a little
bit about what we learned
studying viruses in soils and in humans
so why do we care about viruses of
microbes i often say
you only care about a virus through the
host that it infects now viruses that
infect humans and human cells like the
current coronavirus world that we're
living in are obviously important they
impact health
but microbes in your body are as
abundant as your human cells and there's
a hundredfold more microbial genes in
your body and those microbiomes in your
body
are increasingly recognized to impact
human health
microbes and soils are also important
did you have cereal for breakfast this
morning
microbes that live in soils help make
the nutrients that feed the plants that
you ate
microbes can help improve crop yields
and
if you just breathe the breath of air
half of the oxygen in that breath came
from microbes ocean microbes or tiny
plants in the oceans that produce
half the oxygen on the planet
now
my interest is more focused on viruses
these microbes are important could
viruses infect them and if so what role
do viruses play
we're going to start in the oceans and
in the oceans we actually didn't think
there were many viruses
people went out with
cultures like e coli and tried to
isolate viruses and didn't get any
however when we concentrated seawater
such as shown here and stained it with a
cyber green dna stain we saw what i call
stars against the night sky where these
big dots are cells and the little dots
are viruses
and so these are big numbers if you
swallow a mouthful of seawater there's
actually 50 million viruses now don't
worry they don't affect your your body
or your human cells they don't even
affect your microbiome they're really of
course designed to infect
microbes that live in the oceans
when we do tracer experiments to
understand their impact we learned that
about one out of three cells in the
oceans are killed per day
and
a challenge in our science is that most
these viruses are completely unknown to
science let alone can be cultured
and when we do other kinds of
experiments to look at gene flow
is moving a gene from one cell type to
another cell to like antibiotic
resistant genes for example
we see that there's a huge number of
genes move per day 10 to the 29th
genes move per day in fact these virus
numbers in the oceans and on the planet
are so big there's thought to be 10 to
the 31 viruses on the planet and if you
put these tiny viruses end to end they
would stretch light years away from
earth
so these are really big numbers
when we think of microbial toxins like
bordetella toxin color toxins sugar
toxin produces toxins it's not really
the microbe that encodes that toxin it's
actually a virus integrated into the
microbial genome that encodes the toxin
so it's understanding these viruses and
and how they work that's really critical
for for so many ways that the oceans
work as well as other ecosystems
but it's been a big challenge to assess
these ecosystem impacts because we can't
do things like
grow the viruses and culture
so we're going to stay in the oceans
here for a while themed on patterns
processes and paradigms and i have a
picture of earth just to emphasize the
oceans dominate earth
70 of the land the surface area of earth
is the oceans and these oceans that
we've studied we've done globally
so focusing on these patterns
i want to introduce the tara oceans
consortium which is a uh
many different principle investigators
international and we sought to study in
the top left the global oceans you can
see the cruise track throughout the
global oceans
uh using standardized perches in the top
right which include literally a sailboat
we'll see a picture of it in a minute
that has all kinds of instrumentation
measuring down through the water column
and specifically looking at both imaging
and sequencing data
and then at the bottom you can see we
studied eight orders of magnitude of
ocean organisms from viruses to fish
larvae this is really a large scale
to try to capture biologically and
globally
and this crazy adventure has been going
on since 2008 and on this sailboat this
is the tara
and this this sailboat has been uh
retrofitted for both um below deck uh
work that we have to work with sensitive
instrumentation and above deck work to
process sea water samples as they come
on board
so this is an amazing research
opportunity to get global samples and
we're interested specifically in viruses
problem is as soon as we start to study
them
most of what we observe is unknown
completely new to science
i'm not talking about sort of a new
variant within one particular species of
viruses i'm talking about
completely new to science and
in fact we had to develop a set of
analytics to handle this
so when we started we had to just start
by cataloging viruses and here's a
picture of where we were when we started
there were 2 000
genomic sequences for viruses and
microbes
when we finished some of our early work
we had augmented those databases from
two thousand to thirty thousand
and in a recent paper we augmented that
a hundred fold to two hundred thousand
virus uh species and and these are many
many more genotypes within these
variants so we had to develop analytics
to be able to classify these as species
and i'll mention more about that later
we also had to develop machine learning
analytics to actually handle
genome-based viral taxonomy and and
that's now a gene sharing based network
approach that's established as one of
the modern ways to look at scalably and
systematically virus taxonomy
so we've got some catalogs now hundreds
of thousands of viruses catalog from
around the oceans what do we start to
see and so this is our cruise track
where the gray dots are where the boat
stopped for 24 to 48 hours and did a
bunch of oceanographic sampling and
the errors between the dots
represent the movement of virus
populations based upon abundances of the
genomes genome-enabled virus tracking
and
what we see when we layer on the ocean
currents is that
these viruses seem to ride or drift with
these ocean currents
now this is not all that interesting and
i'm going to come back to it later but
it's kind of exciting to think we can
use genomics to be able to track the
flow of viruses through a complex system
as large as the global ocean
beyond genomic tracking we can also just
simply identify who are the viruses that
are there and so we've done that pretty
extensively at this point and and one of
the most abundant viruses is a virus
called t4 and many of you probably heard
of this virus because it's the basis of
most the molecular biology
reagents that are used to do
fundamental laboratory experimental
manipulations
t4 is a
was studied for decades now for its
molecular biological properties and for
that reason has very useful
enzymes and reagents for molecular
biology
another character though i'd like to
introduce is phi 381 and most of you
have probably never heard of phi 381 i
hadn't either we happened to get it into
culture and we'll see some of the work
that we've done with phi 381 later
to make it one of the most well
characterized viruses on the planet and
here the third most abundant virus genus
in the global oceans
so these kinds of global ocean
patterning data just very simple
descriptive information of who is there
allow us to create diversity anomalies
when we place this information into
predictions about what the oceans will
look like for models and that allows us
to plan things like how will fisheries
catches change in response to climate
change
how should we
set up marine protected areas so that we
get the biggest bang for the buck or
where we're trying to preserve areas of
the oceans
and so that's very valuable uh applied
aspects of this very simple first
description of what viruses who who are
the viruses that are there and what are
their abundances like throughout the
global oceans
the next vignette within oceans i want
to focus on is processes so how are
viruses impacting processes and before
tar oceans from cyanobacterial viruses
in culture
we had learned that viruses impact
processes in the cyanobacterial system
through metabolic reprogramming using
auxiliary metabolic genes or amgs
and in particular they stole
the core photosystem reaction center
genes
so
this is what we think is happening this
is a photosynthetic membrane
in a cyanobacterium for example
where we have
two photosystems ps1 and ps2 embedded in
the photosynthetic membrane and a photon
of light would strike the first
photosystem
excite an electron
pass that through a series of electron
donors to the second photosystem
where a second photon of light would
strike
inside another electron that electron
would be passed to ferridoxin and onto
other reactions
the viruses
almost all
steel
the core photosystem ii reactions that
are protein called pspa
now this is an important protein because
it it splits water to make hydrogen and
oxygen so important in fact that four
nobel prizes have been one studying this
kind of a reaction center
viruses also steal
other genes here i've highlighted the
the cognate pair of psba tspd as well as
highlight inducible proteins plasticine
and ferridox
these we think are drawing electrons
away from the ps2 reaction center to
keep it going
and i forgot to mention the psda protein
because of its proximal to splitting
water into oxygen
hydrogen actually creates oxygen
radicals and turns over on the scale of
30 minutes in every
photosynthetic cell
so the virus really is encoding genes
which help keep this photosystem in
place
and in particular
might function with respect to rate
limiting steps that feed back to making
more viruses
so we think of this as
viruses probably randomly steal genes
from their microbial hosts
and that makes sense because we know
viruses tend to mispackage dna for many
reasons
and
those genes which have a fitness
advantage here in a cyanobacterial
photosynthetic cell to keep
photosynthesis going
they could be
selected for in that virus genome and
kept around so these
virus photosynthesis genes are important
for these cyanobacterial viruses which
need photosynthesis during their
infection
so what they are from tara oceans is
photosynthesis the only thing out there
no not at all in fact there's lots of
central carbon metabolism genes
scattered across viruses throughout the
pacific ocean and other global oceans
there's sulfur cycling genes and
nitrogen cycling genes scattered
throughout virus
genomes in in the tardis data sets so
there's lots of ways that viruses have
collected key metabolic genes
and
alter the biogeochemistry or the
processing of these key nutrients in the
oceans
and another interesting element is which
i won't show is that we've actually
looked at the evolutionary history of
some of those photosynthesis genes in
particular psba and pspd and shown that
the virus version
evolves in the virus in a different
selective constraints and can par and
part of that can be put back into the
cyanobacterium altering the
photosynthetic trajectory of the
cyanobacterium so so there's a real
interesting interplay between viruses
and their own fitness advantage and the
coevolutionary history of these
cyanobacterial cells
so we're going to walk through three
paradigms that i think are new ways we
think about how the oceans work as a
result of our viromics contributions
and the first one is focused on the idea
of virus sequence space
for my research i would like to be able
to identify viral populations in
environmental data and the problem is
that virus genomes are typically thought
of to be rampantly mosaic or or have
some sort of
genetic continuum
akin to like the quasi-species concept
and rna viruses so if we just sort of
pictorially look at this on the left
would be a scenario where gene sequence
space of the yellow viruses blends into
that of the green viruses blends into
that of the dark green viruses blends
into that of the blue viruses so where
would you actually draw a line is there
any discreteness in this genome sequence
space to where you could actually draw a
line about
biological entities
and the right case which we would hope
for would be that yellow viruses
exchange genes maybe across these
populations but that there's a big gap
between
the genome sequence space of the yellow
viruses from the blue from the green
and so we were interested in
asking okay the paradigm would be left
for viruses but it turns out that really
the paradigm for what genome sequence
space might look like is driven by
fast evolving viruses single-stranded
dna and rna viruses
we know that double-stranded dna viruses
evolve much more slowly
could it be a different story
and so
if we go out and isolate viruses from
the oceans i spent 10 years doing that
in my phd in postdoc you get this as a
representation of cyanobacterial virus
genome sequence space so these gray dots
are 10 years of my efforts on many hosts
and many seawater samples to isolate and
sequence genomes
we invented a new method um well so then
when we went in isolated genomes from
one seawater sample we got the blue dots
which you'll see are almost as spread
from four genomes as all of that that i
found all over the world's oceans with
many different hosts
and then we invented a method that could
look at 10 to the 7th viruses in the
10-minute experiment this is called
viral tagging and this led to the red
dots where we saw all of sequence space
covered and
we got variation within each of these
populations
and what you can see is that in no case
does the variation the cloud of of
reconstructed
population genomic sequence space
overlap with another cloud where you
think it does if you look into the
third axis it's the end of the page axis
that is separating them
so this suggests that
in a wild seawater sample with a single
cyanobacterial host that there's
population structure
and when we do follow on experiments
that
specifically looked at using a
population genetic metric of biological
species we saw from 142
complete cyanophage isolate genomes from
the same seawater samples
that these are consistent with a species
gene flows higher within them between
these groups
differential population selection
and these are fixed
genomic features
as well we can look in other systems
outside the cyanobacteria and see that
the cut offs this 95 percent eni or
greater than five percent ani divergence
which is average nucleotide identity
those cutoffs are a good cut off not
only for cyanobacteria but also for um
heterotrophic viruses where we did
phenotyping with a pseudoalthormonus
page
now beyond species as i mentioned
earlier there's the gene sharing
networks and these
we can get a genus level taxonomy using
that machine learning approach
so this is helping us rethink about
virus sequence space what about
the ocean carbon pump and you should
care about the ocean carbon pump because
it turns out half of the carbon dioxide
that we humans put in the atmosphere
is absorbed by the ocean
and when the ocean absorbs all that
carbon
it actually interacts with water through
gerum chemistry to become acidic
and we've shown now through decades of
just monitoring in both the middle of
the pacific ocean and the middle of the
atlantic ocean that humans have
successfully acidified those massive
ocean basins of the pacific and atlantic
oceans
and that's happening due to increased
co2
uh diffusing from the atmosphere
into the oceans
so for that for decades we've been
interested in how the ocean carbon pump
works and and i mentioned earlier that
our genomic trapping tracking result was
not that interesting viruses don't swim
um and so
of course they ride the ocean currents
what i didn't show you is that there's
also x's at each of those
uh many of these sites so the x is an
example of viruses sinking
now viruses have a low reynolds member
so they shouldn't sink
how could viruses be sinking
and the paradigm in our
in our environmentology is that viruses
in the oceans would infect bacteria and
phytoplankton
and this would lead to cell lysis which
can result in particulate and dissolved
organic matter
it then becomes food in a very
nutrient-starved surface ocean
for being recycled
by those same bacteria and phytoplankton
populations and this is called the viral
shunt and the idea is that viruses
should keep carbon small
and prevent carbon from sinking
but an alternative idea was proposed by
marcus finebauer that you could actually
get these localized particulate organic
matter to stay very localized as
aggregates and those aggregates are
deep enough to sink out of the water
column and could contain sticky viruses
in them so that could lead to carbon
export
as well viruses when they infect cells
maybe preferentially
virus-infected cells may be
preferentially grazed and there's
actually data before and against this
depending on the model system you look
at
so
huge question are viruses
leading to
altering the ocean's biological carbon
pump and we decided to test this with
what we call genes to ecosystems
modeling
and
the idea is that you you have lots of
sequence data telling you what the
organisms are and where
you run those through machine learning
analytics and ecosystem modeling
analytics and you ask what is the the
best prediction for the data observed
and in our case we were interested in
the sailboat's trajectory
and
our estimate of carbon flux which is
pictorially represented here down into
the water column
where red are high areas of carbon flux
and blue are low areas of carbon flux
and we're interested in the simple
question remember tara ocean studied
viruses to fish larvae so which of the
organisms in that spectrum drive carbon
export in the oceans
and so we applied these
these machine learning and ecosystem
modeling analytics and we found that
viruses better than any other organism
in fact could explain 89
of the variation in carbon flux which in
ecology
which is in complex communities you
never explain 89 of the variation of
anything in nature that's a really big
strong signal and so it really suggests
that viruses are forming these
aggregates and leading to carbon export
as indicated by the x's in that earlier
plot
now some of you still don't perhaps care
about oceans and carbon export and i
totally appreciate that um but this
this machine learning and ecosystem
modeling analytic is generalizable so i
could have been in another system and
looking at thousands of microbes or
viruses and asking questions about which
ones best predicts disease or soil
health or product yields
and what i didn't tell you is we don't
just know from this early study that
viruses best predict we actually can use
leave without modeling to figure out
which ones are the most important ones
and so we actually know sort of the top
five viruses so out of thousands we know
which few to focus our studies on
so the third paradigm i want to reach
out about here is phage resistance and
and the idea here is that phase
resistance is simple
here we've got a cell with its
genome represented in the inner circle
and we've got a virus which might affect
it so absorption is the first step
resistance could occur
and then the secondary step is that
maybe the virus can get its dna inside
uh it absorbs but there are defenses
like crispr abortive infection proteins
or restriction modification systems
and the third is that in the oceans a
virus may not find the right host so it
founds and finds an alternative host and
it may just simply not have the right
molecular machinery to
tunes to be able to make
the takeover process efficient so
mismatched utilization of the host
machinery
so the idea here is
in the lab if we can make a genetic
mutant that's a very abrupt change
targeted and so single changes are found
to drive resistance and we wondered is
this also true in nature and so
our effort to set up an experiment goes
like this
we had
one phage which infected
a bacteria deities host
well
and another alternative bacteria's host
poorly
the two bacteria deities had identical
16s sequences
but were isolated from water such that
background mutations around the genome
had occurred
and the virus is this fellow i mentioned
earlier phi 381 which is the third most
abundant ocean virus genus globally so
so a very ecologically important virus
so again it infects one host well we see
clear plaques
we see a nice one-step absorption curve
we see phase production after 80 minutes
and the same virus on a 16s identical
host please terrible plaques
no clear one step and no obvious phase
reduction after four hours
we did some work with
a single cell molecular probe technique
we developed called sage fish which
shows that this is inefficient infection
it's not just a lysogenic infection
and so we asked the question with time
resolved multi-omics data sets
what is happening why is this alternate
host strain inefficiently infected
and what we found was first that yes
absorption is part of the problem um 30
poorer absorption based on absorption
connect experiments
we also found however that fewer cells
were successfully infected just due to
failure to block restriction
modification systems and this was data
we were able to infer from both phage
fish and the multi-omics datasets
again we found more evidence that the
host defended against
this infection by both degrading phage
dna and proteins and stalling their
ability to make phage dna and proteins
so this is really different than the
abrupt single mutant change this
suggests that what i call nature's
mutants identical 16s sequences
cells isolated from the same water
column but have slowly drifted
nature's mutants reveal resistance to
phages is not simple here there's at
least four ways that this cell is being
inefficiently infected
now to complement this kind of work we
also do um work to understand what are
called virus cells
the idea that the virus-infected cell is
quite different than um than the
non-virus-infected cell and trying to
characterize that using time-resolved
multi-organs data sets
and uh as well we're interested in how
virus cells respond to nutrient
deprivation into grazers
so hopefully there's a picture at this
point that um that even though i just
study viruses we try to really do it in
in a broad ecosystem context and and
that's really powerful here for example
if we were just um focused on the leg of
this elephant we might say it's a tree
or if we were just focused on the tail
of the elephant we might say it's a rope
but obviously where we're all sitting
where we can see the whole elephant we
realize it's an elephant and i'll just
emphasize that tar oceans is really
pioneering and leading many of these
integrative approaches and also to ohio
state where i'm where i'm at we've got
some really amazing
institutions in place now with the
center of microbiome science which is 80
faculty across nine colleges sharing and
creating resources and microbiome
science tools
and a new nsf-funded biology integration
institute
called emerge which we'll show a little
bit of data from here in a moment
now if you're not at ohio state and you
want to study viruses we've also tried
to develop tools that will democratize
the capability of doing uh this virus a
microbe viromics
so this ivirus tool is that cybers and
that's the workflow pictured in that
figure this cyber's compute is free
provided by nsf anyone in the world can
use it
we've extensive documentation on the
live protocols at protocols.io this
allows the community to tell us when
we've gone wrong and give us feedback on
what's working and not working
we also
have put out a number of benchmarking
papers where we we're recognizing issues
that are coming up in the field uh
people not knowing which tool to use for
a certain step and so we've done
benchmarking analyses to provide
guidance for the field to make it easier
and easier so students don't lose months
and months of time troubleshooting
things that should be worked out
and we've held a number of byromix
workshops training hundreds of people
from around the world
in these years already and then our next
one is um i forgot to update this
october this year october 2021 we've
delayed it since last october
um and it will be virtual
so that's ivirus
so that's the oceans and i want to shift
gears for the last part of this talk to
very simple vignettes in the soils and
in humans
so our virus is important in soils and
there was a recent review paper
that's that looked at this there there
are known to be a lot of viruses that
are abundant in soils but a recent
review paper suggested if we look at all
of the features like physical chemistry
um and down here viruses uh that might
structure bacterial communities
it was proposed that predation and viral
lysis is the least important
of structuring microbial communities now
in the same
review article
there was a section entitled viruses in
their role in the soil microbiome which
basically said but i guess we don't
really know much at all about it yet and
so maybe placing them on this spectrum
isn't so
uh refined yet but we were interested in
whether this might be the case and so by
we i'm part of a soil consortium that
was called isogenia and involved a lot
of pis they're they're listed here and
these isagini this ice genie project
grew into that emerge biology
immigration institute that i just
mentioned
so we're interested in a model ecosystem
in sweden called sterdal and meyer and
this has been
a long-term ecological research station
in a very beautiful location
uh up in in northern sweden and heavily
instrumented to be able to look at lots
of ecosystem science related
flexes and measurements of interest
and it is an area of active saw
and so we looked at the the field site
and identified essentially three classes
of
this is a natural saw gradient where we
had some areas that were dry permafrost
pulsa
some that were intermediate saw that
were sphagnum dominated then phant bog
and then some that were fully thought
are you from dominated
fan
so from this permafrost law we'd
sequence hundreds of bulk metagenomes to
look at their microbial uh signatures
and and out of that uh we mined viral
populations uh nearly two thousand
so what a so we're seeing viruses first
of all they're clearly present and and
those numbers are getting quite high
we've doubled known soil viral genera
most of these viral populations appear
to be active
a big question in soils is whether
viruses are are just
inactivated or relic
in response to
soil and
physical chemical interactions with soil
particles
and minerals
beyond them being active it looks like
they they're predicted to infect a lot
of the key carbon cycling microbes and
they can even encode carbon cycling
auxiliary metabolic genes like the
photosynthesis story i mentioned for the
oceans
so it seems like soil viruses should be
playing important roles and we're now
trying to
build this by new biology information
into predictive models
and so to wrap up with the humans uh
focus work um we'll spend a little bit
more time here
uh and with the emphasis on a lot of the
capabilities we developed in the oceans
really help in the clinic specifically
um first just by establishing
quantitative surveys and the ways to
actually uh look at the data how do you
count how do you model
because it turns out studying viruses is
different than studying microbes or
microbiomes
second is augmenting databases in the
oceans we've augmented the databases a
hundred fold
and so just to give you an example of
that impact we applied our oceans
approaches to establish a very simple
idea the gut virum database
and in this we basically took all
published
studies 32 published studies
of of birom data and then
microbiomes that have not yet been mined
for viruses
two thousand people um 2700 metagenomes
some bulk metagenome some virus-like
particle enriched and out of that we
identified 33 000 of our populations
which is a species level designation so
a single paper
for example 33 000 viral species
in this it turned out that it didn't
matter really when we did a
meta-analysis whether you were diseased
or healthy
it mattered more whether the samples
were processed in lab a or lab b
because the methods being used across
these different papers were so different
that the methodological signal
flooded the disease status signal and so
this is something in the oceans that
we've worked hard for about the last 15
years developing systematic community
consensus approaches so that we have
quantitative systematic comparability
across sample sets and so we'll make we
made that recommendation that that this
signature is a problem and then we also
did learn some of biology we learned
about the kinds of viruses and the
relative richness and how riches changes
in the course of the human life
looking at the impact of aging on the
viral communities
so
so that's sort of
in the human setting in particular
studying viruses in relation to aging
viruses and microbes in relation to
aging
we could also as we talked about earlier
look at resistance and and this might
enable really a 100 year old idea of
phage therapy
the idea that a virus can infect a cell
and might lyse it and affect another
cell and may not lyse it why what are
the mechanisms for that
and so we would care about this because
there are
superbugs or
multi-drug-resistant
antibiotic-resistant bugs and
a number of them are listed here and so
as an alternative to antibiotics for
these drug-resistant
antibiotic-resistant bugs you might use
phages or viruses that could infect this
particular superbug and kill it
where does viral ecology come in well we
actually have
because of the complexity of natural
systems we're always looking for
scalable high-throughput approaches and
we've got lots established in genetics
genomics
capturing characterization methods like
viral tagging that i mentioned earlier
and linking viruses to hosts
so viral ecology can really i would say
change the speed at which we can enable
and empower phage therapy
so there's three ways that viral ecology
can help a fourth way is simply this
idea of ecosystems level understanding
and and here the hypothesis would be
that many complex diseases have
microbial or viral underpinnings where
the ecology of those interactions might
matter
and just as an example i'm going to talk
about autism
here
we have
a connection between autistic children's
symptoms
behaviorally in the clinic with their gi
symptoms they often have a lot of gi gut
problems and when people studied the gut
as a result they found that bacterial
diversity decreased and particularly
fermenting bacteria
tended to decrease in the autistic gut
and there was no information on viruses
and so we collaborated with um greg
caporazzo jim adams and rosie chronic
brown to try to understand in a
controlled pilot open label study so
this is a very small study
we tried to understand how
fmt fecal microbiota transplants in a
sustained manner over 10 weeks could
impact
symptoms
and what we found is that the gi
symptoms decreased
uh quite significantly and the number of
children with autistic simple
symptoms in the clinic were behaviorally
recategorized and as improved
and we now track the virus and the
bacteria that correlate with these
improvements and so with this kind of as
a baseline you'll remember earlier i
mentioned these ecological machine
learning and ecosystem modeling
approaches can take the thousands of
microbes and viruses we see in the gut
and identify the few that matter and
then you can do follow-up work on those
few so it's a great
first approach to understand which
microbes or viruses should i be studying
and beyond autism or aging that i've
already mentioned we've got projects in
phase therapy uh we're looking at
how smoking impacts the lung microbiome
environment uh as well as spinal cord
injury and how that impacts and is
impacted by changing microbiome
those are all published in addition we
have several ongoing studies looking at
other
human comorbidities or diseases
so in summary
i view viruses as nanoscale entities
that are of global importance so here on
top of the world and i've tried to share
with you the idea that we've developed
really good systematic quantitative
sampling approaches i didn't mention it
but we can work with almost nothing
these are quantitative approaches down
to 100 pentagrams of material which is
something like seven
orders of magnitude less than is
recommended for standard library
preparations so we've got really well
characterized systematic sensitive and
quantitative approaches
we've used these in the oceans to
establish a global catalog of the
viruses that occur we've established
machine learning analytics to be able to
do genome-based taxonomy because
virtually everything we see is new
hundreds of thousands of new virus
species in a single paper in the oceans
and then we've used these information
from these virus catalogs and their
abundances and their ecologies in genes
and ecosystems modelings and and in the
oceans that were specifically to show
that viruses drive carbon flux
supporting this hypothesis that virus
aggregates form and that leads to virus
thinking and carbon export in the oceans
we've also applied these kind of methods
and soils in particular thawing
permafrost gradient to be able to
look at how soils as they saw
may impact climate change
and in humans we've been using these
approaches both in phage therapy
contexts as well as in
trying to look at microbial and or viral
underpinnings of complex diseases
i also mentioned ohio state's an amazing
place right now due to the center of
microbiome science which is big and
broad and
very focused on cutting-edge training
and the emerge biology integration
institute which provides a great
multi-omics data integration platform
for sending climate change that could
easily be generalizable to other complex
systems
and this kind of work involves lots and
lots of people i'm highlighting
particularly the trainees as i went
along and again here
who had contributed or driven much of
this work as well as several consortia
and
sequencing partners for this large-scale
kind of efforts and the funding agencies
thank you
dr sullivan thank you for that
informative presentation and we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on that ask a question box located on
the far left of your screen
so let's take a look we already have
some questions coming in from our
audience
dr sullivan are you studying all viruses
or particular kinds of viruses
um yeah so we're currently
the approaches that i've described here
today are related to double strain of
dna viruses and
focused on viruses of microbes the
methods
these days are also applicable to
single-stranded dna viruses and we're
working on
methods for large-scale rna virus
surveys
thank you so much and
one audience member wants to know can we
use viruses to help mitigate climate
change
yeah i think five years ago i would have
said no way and i worry about that but
i'm i'm also uh growing increasingly
concerned that climate change is a
problem
humans don't want to recognize yet so if
we're to think about um the impact of
climate change and we're to think about
whether we can understand the oceans to
the point
to engineer them to help us fight this
you know worldwide problem
i'm kind of beginning to think i want to
say yes that we could use viruses to
help us
mitigate climate change
uh i'd like to see a little bit more
work done in a few key areas where you
were the obvious place to set up large
scale experiments in the space but
but i i think a lot more i'm in an
engineering department i think a lot
more about engineered solutions to
complex problems like these
thank you so much and again i want to
thank our audience for these great
questions and comments you definitely
have some fans in the audience today who
are
commenting about how wonderful this
presentation is
we have one more question coming in
where do i go to find tools and
resources that you've described here dr
sullivan
yeah uh so all of our work is open
access and so available for the
computationally um advanced person
through github repositories and the like
uh but we also have built out a lot of
these analytics on ivirus which is this
platform on the nsf-funded cybers cyber
infrastructure
and so there's a lot of resources there
there's a lot of tools and workflows are
well characterized in some of the papers
so we hope it's helping democratize
everybody's ability to see viruses
in any complex data set sequencing data
set
and if you have suggestions for how to
prove that we're always looking for
feedback
absolutely dr sullivan it's been a
pleasure thank you again for your
important presentation and your
incredible research
would you like to provide any closing
remarks for our audience before we go
just uh to look out for that our our
viromics workshop uh that will be a
little different this fall next month is
going to be focused on three key areas
we see is a bit of a mess in the field
right now we're gonna have um three
experts in each of those sessions so so
that'll be a nice opportunity for the
field to engage and if you're new to the
field to kind of
learn some new things to not lose time
on that research and
and you know please let us know if
there's any
bottlenecks in your own work we're
constantly trying to help people out
there
uh easy do this kind of work much easier
absolutely and again i want to thank you
for your time today before we go i also
want to thank our audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions and any questions we did not
have time for today no cement submitted
on on demand period will be addressed by
our speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
for two years until september 9 2023 lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time take care
everyone and be safe bye